what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Matt Walsh highlights
on Dr Phil before I start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in and sign
up for our memberships when you have a
chance the memberships are very
important to the channel and help
support all of our new equipment and
whatnot like we just had a camera stolen
so let me get a new one anyways um put
the video up and that's a question I
would like to throw out to you know
other members of the panel actually
because just like the four-year-old
can't answer what is a girl
well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it can even tell you
what these words means like what is a
woman can you tell me what a woman is no
I can't
because it's not for me to say I
Womanhood looks different for everybody
what do what do you define a woman as no
it doesn't what do you mean it looks
different from oh no oh my God these
people are so weird uh and what does a
female mean
with female reproductive organs okay
someone who's you know here's the thing
when you're when you're a female it goes
right down to your bones your DNA so
that's why if someone dies okay we could
dig up their bones 100 years from now we
have no idea what they believed in their
head but we can tell what sex they were
because it's in it's down in it's it's
ingrained in everything oh my God can
you imagine archaeologists digging up
these trans people I mean it would still
it would still be like the bones but I
guess all their stuff would be gone by
then wouldn't it like it'd be decayed
but I'm just imagining like finding
these like people they're chopped off
like you know it just they would be so
confused of their being interesting so
I'm trying to understand your definition
is that it always seems to be like men
try to be women it doesn't seem like
it's as common for women to try to be
men I mean I didn't say life was easier
as a girl but but I would be very
curious to know because I think that
would indicate something right if more
there are trans people that are like are
there more men or more women who is
female you said right correct there's a
biological female so what happens if we
have maybe someone who is female
identifies as a woman right you know
cisgender woman right as you explain as
you just explained I'm not a cisgender
woman I'm just a woman you crazy people
but maybe it doesn't have the ability to
reproduce
well maybe doesn't have those organs
that you're talking about that are
reproductive organs I have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a Womanhood is something that just as
Ethan explained I cannot Define because
I am not myself so what did you mean
when you said trans women are women if
you don't know what it means right so
here's the thing so I do not Define what
a woman is because I do not identify as
a woman Womanhood is something that is
an umbrella term wait he
I'm so confused what is that I thought
that was a dude identifying as a girl is
it a girl identifying as a dude do you
know what that is I I couldn't tell you
I'm sorry I'm not even trying to bully
the person I just like genuinely don't
know what you are it includes people
that describes what
people who identify as a woman identify
as what as a woman what is that was to
each their own each one okay see this is
why I'm confused it's got the nails a
beard the long hair and heels like this
is this is a lot I it seems like that
person is a dude right do you think it's
a dude King no no no but like what do
you if like biologically what do you
think that's a dude yeah okay person is
going to have a different relation with
their own gender identity and Define it
differently it's a trans women are women
too
[Applause]
[Music]
you want to reduce men down to maybe
just their genetics or genitals our
chromosomes right who the hell is
clapping I just want to know who's
clapping for this oh my what Society do
we live in Jesus what you want to do is
appropriate women you want to
appropriate Womanhood okay and turn it
into basically a costume that could be
there should be no construct of gender
just sex you're either male or female
right and someone feeling in a mental
emotional way that they don't identify
with the sex that they have been
biologically created as and assigned at
Birth Dr Phil I don't where does he
stand on this he cannot Dr Phil cannot
agree with these crazy people there is
no way based on their genitalia if they
don't feel that way that there's no
construct that describes that
experiences that well that's got nothing
to do with the reality so you can feel
however you want I mean I could sit here
and say that I feel like a tomato plant
but actually in those things so your
your self-perception you can have
whatever self-perception you want but
you can't expect me to take part in that
self-perception or to take part in this
kind of charade this theatrical
production you don't get your own what
if I said I feel black got like a bunch
of spray tan like the Rachel dalza or
whatever chick am I then black these
people are nuts these people are crazy
just like you don't get your own
prepositions or your own your own
adjectives you know it's like if I were
to tell oh I want to I want to identify
as your majesty so yeah anytime anytime
anyone sees me call me Your Majesty
please
my adjectives are handsome and Brilliant
and no matter whatever you're talking
about me you have to describe me as
handsome and Brilliant because that's
how I identify it makes no sense you
don't get your own pronouns these are
that's that's grammar that's language so
you think it's a delusion someone is
self-delusional yeah I think it's it's
delusion it could be a mental illness it
could be it's a lot of different with
children you know there's also just a
basic confusion that all kids have okay
I don't know what else you would call
what is what else would you call
genuinely thinking you're another gender
but I just don't know what else you
would call that if I genuinely thought I
was black like people would say I was
delusional and I would agree but what
are we supposed to call like that's why
when you hear when you hear someone a
parent say oh my four-year-old uh son
cave came to me and said that I'm a girl
now and so that's what I'm gonna I'm
gonna raise him as a girl no you're a
four-year-old I have four kids when a
four-year-old boy comes to you and says
oh I'm a girl here's a good follow-up
question what is a girl ask him what he
means by that what do you mean by a girl
and when you ask him that here's what
he'll tell you he will tell you what he
really means is that he he wants to do
some of the things that girls do like
play with a dollhouse or or you know he
likes the color pink that's fine play
with the dollhouse but you're still a
boy there's the extreme approach that
you are admittedly taking
um and then there's also thanks just
ordinary people that might not be
comfortable with the language change
oh my gosh oh my God this is a professor
what what could you look do me a favor
look up the tuition at Kent State
University just just Google like average
to Mission Kent State University okay
okay so imagine you send your kid for
forty thousand dollars for four years
and you know let's say you got half off
maybe your kid got a scholarship
whatever we all know the ticket prices
aren't the real prices in America right
let's say it's twenty thousand and this
is what they have teaching your child
imagine how how would you feel it's like
oh my God they paid this is what the
conservatives mean when we say the left
has taken over schools and we are paying
to get our kids brainwashed it's awkward
and so they're afraid of not being
courteous or being accepting so there's
like these two things there's actually
combating and not being you don't like
transgender the idea of transgender
that's different than pronouns but then
just for most people it's just feeling a
little bit awkward and unsure and not
wanting to hurt or offend somebody well
why is it important for educators to
teach about gender identity gender
presentation and pronouns why why do you
think that's important because there
there is a difference there is
biological sex and a lot of times people
are conflating sex and gender so there's
biological sex and then there's gender
and that's a social construct in the
sense that
oh my gosh I'm sorry I'm trying to stop
I didn't realize that oh my God it's
taking the lord's name in vain I guess I
guess it technically is I've just never
thought about it I'm trying to I'm
trying to be better guys hold me to it
comment section oh my goodness forty
thousand dollars for four years that you
would spend for that this girl doesn't
know the difference between a man and
okay I'll just let her just because
you're born biologically a female it
doesn't mean you automatically want to
vacuum for instance which is usually a
feminine
um activity or conflated that way
um and so it's this idea of giving
children uh in age-appropriate ways and
understanding that you can that these
things aren't set in stone gender
identity is not tied to biology you say
that gender's not set in stone uh what
do you mean I mean I mean that's just
factually incorrect uh saying that so
you have biology is the chromosomal
makeup and and reproductive organs and
all of that um and so that would be sort
of the nature side of things but the
nurture side of things is where we see
more of gender identities she began by
saying that my view is Extreme okay so
the view that every single person on
Earth has held up until 15 seconds ago
is Extreme and the view that almost
everyone does right now it still still
holds extreme apparently according to
her but there is this complete they are
conflating gender and sex because on one
hand they say well you got your
biological sex but then your gender is
whatever social construct but then they
turn around and say that trans women are
women so a man who who identifies with
the with the the gender the social
construct of Womanhood actually is a
woman so if you can't you can laugh all
you want but you are this is a logical
problem you are a conflating sex and
gender just by saying that so that's the
problem there's biological sex and then
there is gender identity part of me
wants to ask why you care so much uh
because it's really not that big of a
deal oh yeah why are they clapping oh my
um I I love it I'd love to answer that
question I care about the truth so so
basic truth matters I want to live in a
society where people care about the
truth and we're grounded in truth
um I care about children and this these
insane ideas about gender are being are
being foist on kids
um and that that bothers me quite a bit
I care about the women who are having
their opportunities stolen from them I
care quite a bit Yeah the the general
neutral bathrooms and locker rooms so I
agree with my fellow my fellow Matt over
here Loudoun County is a famous case of
the daily wire we helped uncover uh
there was a gender non-conforming boy in
a dress who went into it to a girl's
restroom and rape violently raped uh a
young girl after that happened that's
when this the school district decided oh
you know what now we're going to open up
the restrooms and uh invite the the boys
in with the girls now here's what
happens because we hear a lot about well
gender non-conforming people transgender
people uh it makes them feel bad if they
don't if they're not given access to the
bathroom as they want well okay so they
have their feelings what about the
feelings of the girls who are getting
raped there are many girls and many
women who are speaking okay and this is
what
um I did a panel with Destiny and
freaking Miami Miami and we we brought
up like the transgender bathrooms and I
come at it from an athlete's point of
view so if you start letting transgender
people into the normal bathrooms okay
you could argue you do the Stalls that
everyone locks like whatever but I'm not
for that either get get them out but but
that's that's their argument right then
next is like the locker room and and the
thing is like I don't want to be exposed
to male genitalia in the locker rooms
and the thing is like anyone that's been
an athlete knows like you're I'm not
trying to but like you're changing
you're you're TR you're just trying to
like it's nice to be in a female only
space and I would be so uncomfortable if
I had to share that space with with a
freaking dude especially a dude that
clearly has mental disorders because he
thinks he's a girl like he clearly has a
mental disorder If he if he genuinely
believes he should be there so now you
want me to be in the locker room with a
deranged person with a mental disorder
not only a dude but a dude with a mental
disorder oh come on come on thank you
Case Closed saying we want privacy in
our facilities we don't want a man in
the in the bathroom with us and then
what we hear from people over here well
we hear from this side I did not say
that we want open bathrooms where anyone
can go in well we hear from this side is
that well their feelings don't matter
we're not we who cares you just have to
deal and that's what they do oh my God
that's what Destiny did he's like oh you
shouldn't care but I do care I don't
wanna I don't I don't want to share the
bathrooms with dudes I'm sorry call me
old-fashioned call me traditional you
know call me call me you know uh I don't
know call me old-fashioned I just don't
want guys in the freaking bathroom all
right because the transgender people are
gender non-conforming people it's it's
their feelings that take priority I'm
not trying to minimize your concern
around it but I don't but but I don't
care she's I mean she can just say we'll
see but it's a safety issue
um and you usually still have another
bathroom that you can go to my daughter
would not feel safe or secure if she had
to share a bathroom or a gender neutral
locker room with boys yeah I agree
especially from an athlete's point of
view I just I just cannot especially
okay especially from an athlete's point
of view I just really do not see the
argument that we would want men in our
locker rooms like I just I think that's
a safety concern and I also think that
you're gonna you're giving me delusional
people like deranged people in the
locker room no thank you um but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
don't forget to like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell and I will
talk to you next time